[Music]
will the dems go broke
for being too woke it's the start of
something that will someday be known as
woke apocalypse
woke up local lips
woke up like this yeah whatever greg
even the voice-over guy doesn't care for
the woke stuff
and the democrats may not be far behind
this week a new york times piece wonders
is wokeness crypt tonight for democrats
by the time a lefty idea gets criticized
at the times it can't be ignored
they're just now realizing stalin wasn't
a great guy columnist thomas edsel cites
several surveys that finds most people
are against campaigns to defund the
police or upend traditional gender norms
and that wokeness says one social
psychologist will hurt them
at the polls quote when people are faced
with a party that seems to want to
defund the police and rename schools
rather than open them all while crime is
rising and kids welfare is falling
the left flank of the party is just so
easy for republicans to run against
so it's really not the ideas that are
bad it's that the ideas will hurt you
politically
so are the pushers of woke starting to
choke check out this ad
i saw last night for awoke dating app
hey you tired of dating apps that don't
let you signal all your virtues
i met my husband on a dating app but
he's always trying to tell me who i
can and can't have sex with and it's
like my body
my choice and that's not okay cupid
introducing woker
the dating app that lets you check your
matches while you check your privilege
let walker put the sex
in intersectionality choose from
political affiliations
including democrat and communist
ethnicity
person of color and white minus 200
points daily outrage level
livid literally shaking moving to canada
and over 6 000 genders added hourly
including
non-binary non-tertiary potpourri and
how dare you assume good
sir walker has so many real-time updates
for the latest bravest focus group
tested opinions
even we can't keep up and that's why
we've even replaced this cis male
voiceover with a strong
powerful woman who just changed my
profile from female to polyamorous sex
worker
you did no i didn't okay fine we changed
it for you
and we're also getting rid of all the
choices woker okay stop
stop the commercial hi everybody ceo and
first among equals at woker
unfortunately our 6 000 gender options
didn't consider gender a social
construct
and due to this act of violence in our
drop-down menus we've just canceled
ourselves
the company is shut down effective
immediately all of you go home
stay miserable and stay woke
good luck good luck
do i still get paid
yes very good very good
joe excellent work as the boom operator
yes yes i think you were
you were born you were born to play that
i can't believe you paid me 60 grand for
that
you know what the you were worth every
penny you know you um unlike david
you're still a comedian you haven't gone
on to
sell sponges
we got a line coming out this summer
[Laughter]
um you're still you're still sticking
with the you're the profession you chose
yes
how is how is woke-ism affecting your
job
or your your your performance at comedy
clubs
uh well it's definitely something you
have to keep in mind it's a very strange
thing that people come out to see a
comedy show
looking to get offended looking to have
a bad time right
uh yeah it's it's not good i think um
i think we need to push back against
this and i think the best way best way
for people to do it is don't
seed the point on language i think what
happens is
because when you hear social justice
almost everyone thinks well i'm in favor
of
justice in a social way right and then
they hear what's happening on the
college campuses and they think well
this isn't what i signed up for
so don't let people prey on you wanting
to do the right thing
to push through this nonsense because it
is they're trying to change words to
mean things that they don't mean anymore
and people aren't going to be able to
communicate with each other the best i
mean
very good at it and the anti-racism
movement
is basically a punitive a punitive um
effort against whites i mean it's
basically saying all white no matter
what yeah but
it's called anti-racism but it allows
people who are part of that movement to
be racist against a race
yeah because their goal is not to
eliminate racism their goal is to be
outraged all the time
and if you look at some of these
professors who are saying
um you know ridiculous term of whiteness
if you have to fight whiteness
well if they want to fight i don't see
any of them giving up their cushy
college jobs
right because the average ivy league let
me put you this way the average
black man in america's income is about
24 000 a year
the average ivy leave graduate can
expect to make six figures about two
years after graduating
so according to this logic why don't we
just give every black man an ivy league
degree
then he will make six figures right it
doesn't work that way
and they should know this because it's
not helping the people they're claiming
to want to help
exactly that's right cat um how should
you push back against something like
this
i just refuse to you know worry about it
too much
don't apologize and of course a lot of
people feel this way
and a lot of people are afraid to say it
so if we all acted
like how we really feel we wouldn't have
to worry about it so much and the people
who
are worried about it and should be
worried about it are democrats and they
have every right to be because
let's say you have a voter who's a
parent and they're saying you know my
my daughter she isn't in school i feel
like she's struggling emotionally
i'm worried about her education i'm
worried about her development and you
have the one side saying yeah we should
open the schools
and the other side saying i notice you
keep calling your child she and her
like are those the pronouns that they
prefer or did you not ask because you're
transphobic
who is going to sound more reasonable
and at a certain point i think people
are going to get frustrated with this
because
i think a lot of them already are they
might just start saying it
you know david i bet this must work you
into a lather
can we use that greg can that be part of
the slogan yes
yes yes you're literally foaming over
this this guy
you're on the cutting edge greg that's
what i like thank you
so um you used to practice comedy now
you're
selling blades yes um it's a natural
progression to get into
get close to razor blades yes what
advice would you give democrats
to handle critical race theory woke-ism
all this stuff because it seems like
they are realizing it ain't it it's
going down a bad
road yeah it's tough you know look i'm
sympathetic to the stated
objectives of a lot of these things but
the
um methods are counterproductive
sometimes it's a little too aggressive
yeah you know you can't like when you
come out say all white people are racist
i
i understand on the academic what the
point you're making or whatever
but like if you're a white guy and you
work the 3 a.m
shift at sunoco yeah and you got a
college professor being like you're the
reason people are suffering
that's a guy who could be receptive to
you yeah but now he's like i don't want
to pay attention to this anymore so
strategically it's like it's you're
hurting yourself and democrats you know
i mean they're they're walking on uh
organically sourced egg free-range
shells
i mean they got to be careful it's tough
though i don't know it's not hard to do
that stuff
i think it's interesting because i don't
there isn't a
face to this uh dr schneider now you're
an academic
you're in college i'm sure you have
friends that are are involved in
critical race theory so i don't want to
put you on the spot
but on a scale of wokeness one being
randy quade
10 being uh the squad
where do you find yourself i agree
exactly with david i think
he put it perfectly it must be the shave
[Laughter]
it must be it must be that's the thing
beautiful thing about razors they bring
everyone together
we all need them we all need them
oh my god is this qvc with that we're on
i don't know man i don't know
but mike you know the thing that what i
find interesting about this
is that there's no head on this serpent
right it's like it's dispersed
throughout all campuses and now it's in
all of our hr departments
uh and it's in the politics it's a
movement in which you can't you can't
actually say
who is in charge of wokeness because
it's it's out there i don't know i i'm
not that optimistic that it's going to
be
uh going away very soon i think it's
going to take a while to to burn itself
out because it keeps changing
yes you know there's no way that you
could say someone has made a demand and
then
no one's going to say okay i guess we're
done yeah i guess we've achieved
our goal because then they're not going
to sell any right people people are
getting rich off of it too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else